[Music]
the
swimming dance is the revenge of the
creation of the world
[Music]
in san martín
formal is a new exception
see
[Music]
the dance
on foot since pre-Hispanic times two
thousand three thousand years before the  arrival of
the Spaniards and it has been preserved
as it is and they have not wanted to change it
and
the ceremony that is
Mayan is done one day before the
celebration of Corpus Christi
it has been preserving that it must be
original costumes original skins the
masks well they do  some
artisans totally 12 who can make
the masks
[Music]
coming soon the dance of the deer is a
very special flute approximately
40 centimeters long a thickness
maybe an inch in diameter
the tempo nothing that is a drum or
exclusively made of wood
like that  this gives them a
blessing of life from their work of their
crops as a sacrifice that is made
is communication through dance
there is communication between the people and
the l  The grandparents and the divine beings
[Music]
especially the whole town comes out to see
all of this and then
national tourists come and foreigners come
[Music]
well for me it is sacred it is deep
constantly there is no repetition of the
existence of grandparents among us
[Music  ]
[Music]